ist unser universum eigentlich ganz
anders als wir bisher angenommen haben
ein forschungsteam von der finnischen
universität uppsala hat jetzt ein
universum ganz ohne dunkle energie und
dunkle materie berechnet eine absolute
revolution und wieder spielt die
stringtheorie eine entscheidende rolle
also was ist los klick zum science
fiction hier gibt es täglich
faszinierendes seines videos abonniert
den kanal nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
herzlich willkommen aus der
teilchenphysik kennen wir das ja schon
nun dort ist es auch schon erforscht und
bewiesen nichts ist so wie es scheint da
gibt es die laut einstein spukhafte
fernwirkung von verschränkten teilchen
was ich mit dem einen teilchen tour
passiert auf dem anderen teilchen egal
wo sich im universum befindet oder
teilchen können sich wie wellen oder wie
teilchen verhalten je nachdem was wir
beobachten das doppel spalt experiment
beweist es beobachten wir durch welchen
spalt die teilchen fliegen entsteht ein
schatten mit zwei spalten hinter dem
doppel spalt beobachten wir die energie
der teilchen entsteht ein
interferenzmuster hinter dem doppel
spalt wie bei wellen
wir können also hier in der wirklichkeit
sehen wie die teilchen respektive wellen
ihre eigenschaften ändern oder die
wahrscheinlichkeit der mit der teilchen
eigenschaften annehmen sehr schön mit
dem gedanken experiment mit schrödingers
katze durch nach die mit einer
wahrscheinlichkeit tot oder lebendig ist
die welt der teilchen ist wirklich
komplett anders als wir hier die
wirklichkeit tagtäglich erleben
es ist schon ein bisschen spooky aber
vielleicht ist ja das nicht nur im
mikrokosmos der fall sondern auch im
makrokosmos unser universum kann nämlich
nicht so existieren wie wir es
beobachten es gibt eine riesige
wissenslücke und die ist 95% groß von 95
prozent des inhalts unseres universums
haben wir einfach keine ahnung dass
besteht laut aktuellen erkenntnissen der
astrophysik aus dunkler energie und
dunkler materie die dunkle energie ist
dabei dafür verantwortlich dass das
universum sehr schnell auseinander
fliegt und zwar schneller als das licht
und die dunkle energie erklärt die
fehlende gravitation die zum beispiel
ermöglicht dass sich galaxien schneller
drehen als eigentlich erklärbar wäre
aber immer wieder werden
diese unbelegte theorie in frage
gestellt weder die dunkle energie noch
die dunkle materie wurden direkt
beobachtet auf der suche nach den
teilchen der dunklen materie hat noch
niemand irgendetwas gefunden jetzt hat
ein forschungsteam von der universität
aus uppsala in finnland eine elegante
lösung entwickelt und diese lösung ist
absolut mein bleiben und setzt an einer
bisher unbelegte theorie an der
stringtheorie und da hat sich ja auch
schon ein anderer forscher daran fest
gebissen professor kommunen wasser von
der harvard university
seiner ansicht nach kann unser universum
so gar nicht existieren in einem
existierenden universum muss zum
beispiel die gravitation viel schwächer
sein als alle andern kräfte das stimmt
hier gravitationswellen als folge sind
nur sehr schwach und kaum zu finden
aber eines funktioniert laut seinen
berechnungen nicht ein universum mit 70
prozent dunkler energie wie wir es ja
nehmen ein solches universum ist laut
bafa unmöglich während wir heute noch
ganz viele nachbargalaxien sehen können
wird das entferner zukunft ja nicht mehr
der fall sein weil das universum
aufgrund der dunklen energie auseinander
fliegt sie sind zu weit weg dann um sie
sehen zu können 70 dessen was existiert
soll diese energie in unser universum
sein doch waffe hat etwas anderes
berechnet und das widerspricht wirklich
so einigen laut seinen berechnungen für
ein existierendes universum auf basis
der stringtheorie darf diese energie
keinen festen wert haben sondern sie
muss sich verändern sprich in einem aus
unserer sicht geschlossenen system wie
unserem universum verändert sich der
inhalt und genau hier setzt das
forschungsteam aus uppsala an ihre these
dunkle energie und dunkle materie
existieren gar nicht was wir hier
beobachten ist eine fünfte dimension die
unsere vielen dimensionen die wir als
raum zeit erleben beeinflusst sie sagen
es gibt eine extra dimension und in
dieser dimension gibt es ein dynamisches
objekt zitat das in einen höheren
sozialen raum eingebettet ist laut dem
forschungsteam kann man es sich wie eine
kugel vorstellen deren oberfläche
dreidimensional ist und unser universum
darauf existiert die strings womit wir
wieder bei der stringtheorie werden aus
denen alles besteht sind mit dieser
kugel in der
fünf dimensionen verbunden und wir sehen
hier die auswirkungen des verhaltens
dieser kugel in der fünften version und
danielson astrophysiker von der
universität uppsala unsere drei raum
maße entsprechen dem rand der blase
während der radius der erwachsenen blase
die zusätzliche dimension ist alles klar
alles klar damit wären zwei fliegen mit
einer klappe geschlagen
die suche nach dunkler energie und
dunkler materie wäre beendet und es gäbe
endlich eine beobachtbare folge der
stringtheorie wir könnten eine der
zusätzlichen dimensionen der theorie
hier im universum sehen und vielleicht
sind wir ja einen beweis schon sehr nahe
um wasser von der harvard university hat
nämlich ausgerechnet wie sich der wert
der vermeintlichen dunklen energie
ändern müsste wenn die stringtheorie
gelten würde
und das ist extrem langsam aber messbar
spricht wenn eine veränderung der
dunklen energie gemessen würde dann wäre
das ein ganz starkes indiz dafür dass
die stringtheorie tatsächlich gilt und
es wäre ein starkes innendienst dafür
dass sie tatsächlich die manifestation
einer sich verändernden fünften
dimension ist haben er ich habe das
thema wie viele andere themen auch aus
den untiefen der wissenschafts
publikationen gesiebt und tiefer
recherchiert die welt in der wir leben
ist einfach unglaublich geheimnisvoll
täglich versuche ich diesen geheimnissen
etwas auf die spur zu kommen wenn er
kein video dazu und zu allen anderen
themen verpassen wollt dann folgt mir
auch ob whatsapp da gibt es die videos
früher als hier auf youtube per
newsletter dafür hier klicken keine
werbung mehr auf klicks um gibt es wenn
ihr mitglied werde der link dazu ist
unter dem video wenn nicht mal am
computer anschauen
und hier geht es weiter mit das ende des
universums bis dann bleibt dran